Hey everybody, welcome to section 4.4 of
your textbook, Random Number Generation.
So I like how they even say, we
now take a brief diversion into
popular type of programming application,
simulation and game, or yeah,
simulation and game playing. So I
guess that's what we're doing too.
Anyways, we're going to talk about
random numbers, which this kind of
goes along with the other things
that we're going to talk about in
the next couple of content videos
anyways, which is external libraries
that we'll import into Python and
use for different purposes. So the
first one is going to be the random
library, and you can see here kind
of how they use that library and
how they import it into their code.
So let me just briefly talk. The
random library and any other library
that you're going to borrow in
Python is code that exists somewhere
else that somebody else wrote that
is widely accessible to anybody.
Now, there are a few that require
some installation packages first. Then
there's also some that kind of come
with Python, but that you still
need to explicitly say import this.
So they're built in in a sense.
And random is going to be one of
those. So when we use the random
library, we import it at the top
of our code. And then whenever we
want to use a function from the random
library, we do random dot whatever
function it is. And if you ever
want to read up more on like...
a specific library or module I
would just recommend googling it and
then you can click on the documentation
for it and documentation I know
looks super scary I don't want to
read that I don't have capacity
to focus for more than 15 seconds
without a bag of popcorn in front of
me whatever it might be but it is
really helpful to read documentation
you can also go to one of my
favorite websites which is w3schools
and type in exactly what you want
to learn more about and w3schools is
amazing because it's a little bit
less just chunks of text on the
screen and a little bit more interactable
so for example you could click
on any of these functions here and
it will tell you more about them
and it will also give you a demo
where you can learn more about the
function and actually use it. So
for example, the ones we're going to
talk about today are rand range
and rand int. So I'm going to click
on rand int and here it gives me a
very easy and simple definition of
what that function does and I can
try it myself. So and it opens up
another interactive page and talks
about syntax, talks about parameters.
So I love, love, love W3 schools
for when you're trying to learn
about Python syntax or just trying
to figure out some different things
for your code. You can also read
the documentation. This is amazing.
Sometimes it's a little bit much
for me even. And so this is a great
thing to paste into an LLM to have
it kind of translate it to you. But
for now, let's jump over to our
code space and we'll talk a little
bit about randoms. Whoops, I added
one too many quotation mark there.
Random numbers.
So we're going to grab two
functions from the random
library, but before we do
anything, we're going to import
random.
You may have also seen people
say import a library as something
else, and that's totally okay too.
I'm just going to import random.
So I want to use rand range.
So I'm going to say
number, let's call it rand
number, is going to be equal
to random dot rand range.
And rand range requires
two arguments, your
starting number and your
up to inclusive number.
And then let's just print out
what that random number is.
Let's say rand range random.
And if we were to run this code, I
would hope we see a random number
including all the numbers between
one and four, but not including
four. And I broke it. It's fine.
Great. Okay, so that's rand range.
The other function is going
to be rand int, which I like
better because it's inclusive.
So here's our rand number two.
We'll call random dot rand
int. Let's do one and four
again. And we'll print randint random.
Hopefully we should see four popping
up, which thankfully I only took
two times running it. So randint is
inclusive, randrange is not inclusive.
So that's basically all you need
to know. Now why would you ever
want to generate a random number
in your python code well then the
possibilities are endless you could be
coding a game that requires dice roll
you could be um trying to like
shuffle a deck and like requiring
random numbers for that you could
be simulating a coin toss so there's
infinite possibilities here and I hope
that your brain has exploded learning
about random numbers so that you
too can code something amazing and
And anyways, that's all for this
content video. Thanks for watching.